[موسيقى]
نحن هنا لأن شركة بوما ترعى
اتحاد كرة القدم الإسرائيلي
الذي يرعى فريق كرة القدم على
أراضي المستوطنات في فلسطين المحتلة،
نفس فلسطين التي
يتم قصفها حاليًا حيث توجد إبادة جماعية،
إبادة جماعية حقيقية ترتكب بحق أكثر من
20 ألف شخص  قتلوا في
الشهرين الماضيين أكثر من 20 ألف شخص،
قصفوا المنازل، قصفوا المدارس، قصفوا
المستشفيات، قصفوا المسك
والكنائس، قتلوا الناس في
أسرتهم، قتلوهم في
الشوارع، أخذوهم إلى الأسفل، وجردوهم من ملابسهم.  ملابسهم
الداخلية ثم أطلقوا النار عليهم
أمام عائلاتهم، هذا ما هي عليه
إسرائيل، هذا ما هو عليه
آران الإسرائيلي RA كولونيل وهذا ما
يستثمر فيه الملاكم، نحن
ندعو الملاكم كما فعلنا مرارًا
وتكرارًا  سحب
عضوية الاتحاد الإسرائيلي لكرة القدم
للتحويل من إسرائيل لاتخاذ
الموقف الأخلاقي، الموقف الصحيح والتحويل من
الإسراء وعلينا أن نتخذ إجراءات مثل
هذه لأنها الطريقة الوحيدة التي يستمعون بها،
نعم لقد حاولنا كتابة الرسائل حاولنا أن
نكون مهذبين  لقد حاولنا أن لا
نخمن ما لا يستمعون إليه، بل
يستمعون فقط عندما يتم إزعاجهم، ولهذا
السبب يتعين علينا القيام بذلك، لكي أكون
هنا، لا أحد منا يريد أن يكون هنا، نريد
أن نكون في المنزل في أسرتنا  لكن
ليس أمام الفلسطينيين خيار سوى القتال
يومًا بعد يوم بعد يوم يتعين عليهم فيه
القتال من أجل البقاء، لذا إذا كنا
سنحترمهم، إذا كنا
سنحترمهم، فيمكننا أن نفعل ما يتعين علينا القيام به،
تعالوا  هنا ومحاربة هذه
الشركات المتواطئة